-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, it is the holiday season,
and today, it even started
snowing here in New York.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it was just a few flakes,
but LaGuardia
shut down immediately.
Well, here's some fun
local news.
You guys aren't
going to believe this.
A guy in Brooklyn
just won $10 million
from a scratch-off ticket
for the second year in a row.
Yeah, he's loving life today.
He marched into his old job
like, "I quit again!"
Well, guys, everyone is
talking about this.
Last night in Alabama,
four candidates took the stage
for another Republican
presidential debate.
Yep. The big winners from
the night were
Nikki Haley, Chris Christie,
and everyone who decided
not to watch.
Yeah, last night was
the fourth Republican debate.
At this point, it's kind of
like "Indiana Jones" movies.
Three was enough.
You know what I'm saying?
Once again, the debate
was kind of crazy.
People are saying it was
pretty controversial
when Vivek Ramaswamy
held up a sign
that said "Nikki=corrupt."
-Ooh!
-I don't think that that's
controversial.
I mean, I think it would be
really controversial
if he held up a sign
that said...
I mean, because that's --
People are --
That is not --
A hot dog is a hot dog.
Meanwhile, Chris Christie
came out swinging
and went after Ramaswamy
and he really didn't hold back.
Watch this. For real.
-You do this at every debate.
-I'll say exactly --
-No, don't interrupt me.
I didn't interrupt you.
This is the fourth debate,
the fourth debate
that you would be voted,
in the first 20 minutes,
as the most obnoxious
blowhard in America.
So shut up for a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Wow!
It is clear Ramaswamy
isn't well-liked.
After he attacked Christie,
the moderators were like,
"Governor Christie,
you have two hours to respond."
At another point
during the debate,
Chris Christie said
the other candidates
were afraid to mention Trump
and treat him like Voldemort,
he who must not be named.
And that got me thinking.
There's actually
a lot of similarities
between Republicans
and Harry Potter.
-Oh, boy. Here we go.
-What's up, Tariq?
-Well, let me guess.
You're going to show,
like, a bunch of side-by-side
photos of Republicans
and then the Harry Potter --
like, the characters
that they look like.
-Yeah, that was the plan.
-Well, I know exactly
how this will go.
So, first, you'll show
a picture of Harry Potter,
and then you'll say he looks
like House Speaker Mike Johnson.
And then, after that,
you'll show a picture of --
I don't know --
probably Draco Malfoy,
and you'll say he looks
like Eric Trump.
And then, finally, after that,
you'll show a picture of --
I don't know -- like,
Neville Longbottom
when he got frozen,
and then, boom,
there he is, Mitch McConnell.
Is that how this is going to go?
-I mean, yeah, yeah,
that was pretty good,
but you're a little off.
Yeah. Because, first,
I'd show Harry Potter,
but then I'd say he looks
like George Santos.
Then, after that,
I'd show Draco's dad,
Lucius Malfoy,
and say he looks like
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
And, finally, I'd show
frozen Neville Longbottom,
but he's more like Ron DeSantis
trying to stand normally.
-I got to give it to you, man.
-Yeah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, everybody.
The debate lasted two hours,
and a lot happened,
so it was honestly hard
to keep up.
Thankfully, we have a remix
to help you out. Check it out.
-Let's get started.
[ Hip-hop music playing ]
-Nikki is corrupt.
-It's not worth my time
to respond.
-That's not true.
-Don't interrupt me.
I didn't interrupt you.
-I have a woman problem.
-The most obnoxious
blowhard in America.
-Walk yourself off that stage,
enjoy a nice meal.
-Don't interrupt me.
I didn't interrupt you.
-They all had man dresses on.
-Get the hell out of this race.
-Don't interrupt me.
I didn't interrupt you.
-Thanks for watching.
Thank you, guys.
-There you go.
Just a little remix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, switching gears, guys,
this is very sweet.
Apparently,
every year for Christmas,
President Biden
gives his wife, Jill,
a personal poem
that he's written.
-Aww!
-Isn't that cute?
Yeah, and this year,
he's been writing a bunch,
trying to find
the right one to give.
And we actually got a hold
of the wastebasket
from the Oval Office
that has some of the rejects.
Should I read
some of them right now?
-I would, yeah.
-This is the official waste...
-Wow!
-...of the Oval Office.
James, can I get some
poem-reading music, please?
[ Soft music plays ]
Oh, that's perfect.
Sweet, right?
This one here.
How about this one? Oh!
-He really crumpled them up.
-This says...
-Aww!
-Isn't that sweet?
-That's cute.
-It's cute.
He did crumble them up.
He did crumble them all up.
Yeah.
-Really hard.
-Yeah. Well, he probably
shoots them in the basket.
-Yeah, probably did that
from a long distance.
So, I mean, that's...
-Oh, there's another one.
-Yeah.
-He wrote a lot of these.
-Yeah. Oh, this is nice.
Well, it's close.
He's cl--
-He's close.
-He means well.
This is the last one here.
-Wow, that one looks glued.
There you go. That's fantastic.
Isn't that nice?
That's cute.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got the wastebasket.
-Wow.
That's so great you got that.
-Yeah. You guys see this?
A new poll found that
New York City Mayor Eric Adams'
approval rating is at 28%,
which is the lowest
in that poll's history.
Yeah, he's pretty unpopular.
Check out this news thing
I saw, local news.
-Mayor Eric Adams' approval
rating is now at a record low,
according to a recent poll.
To put that in perspective,
he's now less popular than...
and even...
-Oh, my God!
That was in the local news.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey...
-Hey!
-Switching gears, I read that,
on a recent flight from Canada,
an off-duty pilot had to step in
after the captain suffered
an uncontrollable nosebleed.
Yeah. This is why
before I board a plane,
I always double-check that
the pilot's not a third grader.
[ Laughter ]
And this made things worse.
Instead of tilting his head back
to stop the bleeding,
he tilted the plane.
-Oh.
-Yeah, it was...
Guys, finally, we have
exactly 12 shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for that
beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters"!
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters" ♪
♪ 12 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we will be giving
one lucky audience member
a spectacular Christmas sweater
from the Countdown
to Christmas Cabinet.
Since there are 12 shows left,
let's open door number 12.
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow. This is gorgeous.
Look at this.
I don't know what that is.
Holy moly.
Alright, now let's see
who's going home with
tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number, okay?
If I call your number,
I need you to jump up
and let me know where you are.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants me
to pick their number?
It's a good sweater.
[ Cheers and applause ]
442!
♪♪
Hi!
How you doing?
-Good. How are you?
-I'm fantastic.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-Maria from Colombia.
-Maria from Colombia!
Oh, my goodness.
Maria, you have
a beautiful sweater on.
Does it get
a little chilly in Colombia?
-Um, no.
-No.
So this is perfect,
because those rare occasions
when it does become chilly,
you're going to have something.
Do you have anything like this?
-No.
-No. Would you like to
try it on?
-Of course.
-Oh, my God.
Guys, give it up for
Maria from Colombia.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got your gla-- Oh.
-Thank you.
-No pr--
Oh, Maria, this is --
I mean, this is gor--
Look at this. That's gorgeous.
Oh, you're a model.
Thank you so much.
Give it up for Maria, everybody.
Thanks again.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Olivia Rodrigo!